hey a quick uh quick note out to all of  you out there that believe  that an open mind is important which by  the way i agree with you i agree an open  mind is important  you know the old saying the mind is like  a parachute  it won't work if it's open but i want  you to add one piece to that  if that parachute is wide open you're  falling straight to the ground you  understand what i'm saying  if it doesn't open if the mine doesn't  open you're in trouble  if it opens too wide your dead man  bouncing  or a dead woman balancing my point to  you is this okay  most people do actually have an open  mind the problem is  many people they have a mind that's wide  open with no filters  no gates no protection you listen to  everyone  you listen to everyone on facebook  everyone on instagram you listen to your  uncle your aunt your mom your dad  when the mind's too open you get too  much data  and you go into confusion